[Music]
what's up guys helen here to talk about
a franchise that's preoccupied with
leather the meaning of existence and did
we mention leather that's right the
matrix and specifically the fourth film
in the series the matrix resurrections
considering the franchise began in 1999
and laid dormant for 18 years the
trilogy has maintained a surprising
amount of cultural relevance a lot of
that was due to how revolutionary it was
from the fight choreography to the
visual effects from the deep world to
the heady themes welcome
to the desert
of the real the ways in which the matrix
influence the trajectory of the
hollywood blockbuster are seemingly
endless but even as the film's cyberpunk
aesthetic waned in popularity the impact
of its ideas only intensified
specifically via the growth of
simulation theory the idea that all of
human life and experience takes place in
a computer simulation and the notion of
having to choose between a blue pill and
a red pill serves as a perennial banner
for many that includes some rather
radical extremists that we're hoping
won't leave us comments telling us to
take a long walk off a short fear it's
in this climate that matrix
resurrections operates one where the
legacy of the franchise is messy the
film seems utterly preoccupied by this
reality seeking to examine the legacy of
the original trilogy and what it means
to pick it up again after more than 20
years so how well does resurrections
accomplish the ambitious goal of
self-interrogation and can it actually
examine or even amend the legacy of its
own franchise throw on some sleek shades
for this wisecrack edition on the matrix
resurrections and major spoilers ahead
for all things matrix and some of blade
runner 2. so how does the matrix
resurrections engage with the legacy of
its own franchise according to co-writer
david mitchell the film's central
conceit is having the trilogy exist as
an artifact within its universe this
artifact takes the form of a video game
series that neo now back in a new matrix
as thomas anderson designed the games
play out exactly as our matrix trilogy
does so of course everybody loves them
and anderson is the toast of geekville
this is my very good friend thomas
anderson he is a bonafide famous person
and considered by most to be the
greatest game designer of our generation
importantly situating the trilogy as an
artifact allows people's reactions to
that artifact to be a central part of
the film this creates lots of capacity
for self-examination an intention
telegraphed from the beginning of the
film where we essentially watch two
characters watching the first scene of
the original matrix but of course
there's no story without some conflict
thomas finds himself literally forced by
warner brothers to make a sequel to the
trilogy despite his oath to let sleeping
leather jackets lie i'm sure you can
understand why our beloved parent
company warner brothers has decided to
make a sequel to the trilogy one and
this is not unlike what happened to the
wachowskis irl but we'll get to that
later it's through this storyline that
in our opinion resurrection's most
directly and most successfully examines
the legacy of the matrix in one montage
the dev team bickers about what the
matrix means obviously the matrix is
about transpolitics crypto fascism it's
a metaphor of capitalist exploitation
they debate about what it means to
revive the franchise matrix means mayhem
and they rationalize just what it would
mean to return to the story over and
over again this cannot be another reboot
retread regurgitation why not
reboot cell this is of course boatloads
of fun but it's also a sly reference to
the franchise's reputation for
opaqueness a quality that facilitated so
many disparate interpretations to begin
with but this scene is also key to
contextualizing the developments and
retcons of the entire movie the dev team
we are made to assume wasn't directly
involved with the initial creation of
the matrix games yet each member seems
to have their own definitive
interpretation meanwhile thomas the
driving creative force behind it all
does kung fu in his apartment and takes
luxurious baths so what's going on well
for us it seems like a microcosm of what
notable french smart guy roland barthes
called the death of the author back in
the late 60s barnes was getting sick of
the way literary critics interpreted
everything through the prism of the
author's life in short he claimed that
if a work is sufficiently complex we
can't reliably glean an author's
intentions from the text alone to barths
this means what the author intended
can't be as relevant as what's in the
actual text itself of course this
opinion was misread and over time was
taken to mean that any interpretation of
a text is valid because the only thing
that matters is how the reader feels
which eventually led to say baseless
speculation that breaking bad was all
just a dream after jesse fell asleep in
mr white's chemistry class or you know
the whole red pill ideology the idea of
the death of the author and its
subsequent misreading have all but
defined literary criticism over the
years so by excluding mr anderson the
author of the game from the discussion
resurrections is depicting the dominant
cultural form of criticism and
acknowledging the franchise's capacity
to elicit varying interpretations but
the film is really most concerned with
one interpretation the self-evident
cesspool that is the red pill movement
before you leap into the comments to
tell us our mom should have had an
abortion know that this is not some
spicy hot take the red pill
interpretation flies in the face of
pretty much every other theme in the
trilogy like realizing free will or
resisting oppression what's more the
central villain of resurrections played
with gusto by neil patrick harris
parrots red pill rhetoric with a
bluntness uncharacteristic for the
franchise
what a mess
i own that mistake shouldn't oppress
women used to be so easy to control
resurrections tries to belie faulty
interpretation that is to make its
intent as obvious as possible and it's
pretty upfront about it trinity is just
as important as neo and by the end of
the movie is even more powerful it's
centering the lead woman of the
franchise in the face of a misogynistic
misappropriation of its ideas by you
know pickup artist it's an assertion of
what the matrix is supposed to mean from
one of the key minds of the series lana
wachowski in this way the film actively
defends the author's right to dictate
how we interpret their works now that's
cool and validating for people who have
interpreted the text correctly according
to that author but the practice of
privileging the author does have
unfortunate implications rooted in class
and notions of elitism regardless of how
it was misread to be a free-for-all orgy
of interpretation barths's death of the
author was instrumental in shifting
literary criticism away from snobby
intellectual circles and opening it up
to anyone willing to engage in close
reading of texts it expanded the field
to accommodate new voices including
those systemically excluded from
academic circles this complicates
resurrection's argument that the author
can swoop in and tell people their
interpretations are wrong that
complication becomes even more gnarly
when you consider the medium of film
which is inherently collaborative when
the final product has had input from a
ton of different creatives who counts as
the author the answer here might seem
obvious it's the wichowski sisters right
the vision for the franchise came from
them and as directors they enacted that
vision but this only works according to
the definition of authorship taken from
literary criticism i.e a singular entity
film theorists in the 60s and 70s
actually did try to appropriate this
approach introducing auteur theory as an
attempt to elevate the way film was
viewed in academic circles auteur
theorists argued that the director
functions essentially the same way as
the author of a book this arguably risks
understating the contributions of say
their writer the cinematographer
production designer and yeah even the
studio executives so film theorists see
paul sellers proposes collective
authorship as a better fit for movies
where the author is an entity made up of
the people who had an artistic effect on
the final product this can get weird
sometimes though take blade runner the
question of whether protagonist deckard
is a replicant or not is alluded to
throughout the film and it's perhaps the
most prominent area of discussion for
fans director ridley scott has been
super vocal about his take scott says
deckard is a replicant and scenes that
would tacitly confirm this were removed
from the theatrical cut of the movie but
pretty much everyone else involved in
making the film including star harrison
ford and the very dudes who wrote the
script disagree scott got to make his
own cut of the film years later and used
the opportunity to all but confirm his
stance
but then again who does situations like
this draw attention to the fact that
even when altering our notions of
authorship to include collaboration the
question of who should have final say
over a film is always going to be tricky
and it gets trickier when we apply
collective authorship to a franchise
because you get studios eager to
leverage their valuable ip sometimes
over the artistic concerns of the
creators in fact warner brothers was
openly developing a fourth matrix movie
for years even though the wachowskis
were not on board in pretty much all of
the biggest hollywood franchises like
the mcu's bonds and fast and furious the
studio was the only consistent party
across the installments philosopher
theodor adorno explored this calling
hollywood out as a major contributor to
what he called the culture industry now
adorno's thoughts on this are sweeping
and occasionally elitist but of note to
us is his exploration of the hollywood
movie as a product according to adorno
hollywood films are defined and
ultimately diminished by their adherence
to formulas he believed that things like
tropes and strict act structures are
used to make films viable as a product
and nothing that might devalue that
product will be tolerated in the culture
industry any meeting that commodified
art wants to convey is at best
compromised by financial concerns we see
this tension at play in matrix
resurrections too which seems to be
constantly apologizing for its own
existence and going on tangents that
explicitly attack the whole notion of
sequels in the first place i felt either
i'm
having a mental breakdown again
or
i'm living inside a computer-generated
reality that has imprisoned me
again at the same time it plays into
plenty of the obvious ip and profit
driven sequel tropes adorno might have
complained about this makes it all feel
a little messy sure the film pokes fun
at the studio but overall it protects
the franchise still it does raise some
interesting questions as it wrestles
with its own existence fittingly the
analyst who produces the matrix to
generate energy feels almost like an
embodiment of the content industry turns
out in my matrix
the worse we treat you the more we
manipulate you
the more energy you produce
it's nuts
i've been setting productivity records
every year since i took over and the
best part zero resistance people stay in
their pots happier than pigs
this seems to be commenting on the way
this industry and its wealthy gurus
thrive on generating controversy and
stimulating heightened emotions in order
to capture the attention of the masses
more so than taking issue with fan
interpretations then the film saves its
most serious criticism for the content
industry at large matrix resurrection
seems to almost be asking am i really
just a good version of space jam 2
another piece of ip leveraged to drive
hbo max subscriptions ultimately this
film seems nervous about its own
existence and the loss of the
wachowski's authorial control amidst
warner brothers zest for more ip-driven
content whether you can successfully
take issue with the existence of
unnecessary sequels within a sequel
however remains an open question as does
the question of how successfully you can
tell people they got your film all wrong
more than 20 years later the way we see
it it's a bit late to undo aspects of
the matrix's legacy that lana seems to
dislike but it was still pretty fun to
watch the film try but what do you guys
think was the matrix resurrection
successful in critiquing its fans in the
content industry or did it get too meta
for its own good let us know in the
comments and hey try to keep it friendly
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support slow motion kick that subscribe
button with the power of a thousand
morpheuses more vi and don't forget to
ring that bell and as always thanks for
watching peace
[Music]
you